janvier 2013
à l'autre bout du monde un film se
prépare avant le tournage le réalisateur
a confié le repérage un diu de
professionnels jane ravenswood cadreuse
colonel au département vidéo de l'us
navy et bob drinking triple champion du
monde de repérage en 2009 et 2010
si bob linking devenu légende dans le
monde du repérage c'est parce qu'ils
n'hésitent pas à jouer lui même les
scènes du scénario et ce afin de donner
réalisateur
vivez tout saisissante possible mise en
scène par l'équipe
l'attak d'udine aux sharks promet d'être
spectaculaire
le script à setubal as-tu poggi just
can't escape qui as to build and far
right thing you do you say avantage
psychologique on aime ty coz et kengo
batou droite heures est louable débauche
tous des styles la mise en scène du pub
est impressionnant les chartistes
fauteuil ou douter qu'un petit pas
a new show est jamais vu de ma vie
l'équipe est maintenant prête à
s'attaquer aux premiers problèmes
d'ordre logistique comment nourrir une
équipe de 300 personnes la noix de coco
sortes de pommes de terre locale est
présente en grande quantité
malheureusement à raison de 35 minutes
d'ouverture par noix de coco x 300 noix
de coco par repas il faudrait à l'équipe
environ 7 jours de travail par repas
la piste est abandonnée après l'échec de
la chasse aux crabes l'équipe décide de
se tourner vers la jungle
utilisons ces connaissances militaires
acquise dans la navy
jane est bob a identifié les nombreux
végétaux comestibles qui foisonnent dans
ces régions luxuriante
la piste est également abandonné
l'équipe se tourne alors vers la pêche
les eaux chaudes et extrêmement
poissonneuses de la région constitue un
garde-manger inépuisables
après des débuts difficiles jane fini
par faire de belles prises l'équipe
décide de rester quelques jours sur
place de modes de difficulté one you
play au character aux wayne rooney ils
tous succèdent to make the differences
between même minimes féminines sexe ni
way to do it to take advantage le jeu
sur les conseils d'un collègue bob
entame des négociations avec un petit
producteur local des amis c'est qu'il
peut des chiens annie de santé oneapp
acheter et blattes ou super star
l'idée de rajouter des singes
radioactive bodybuildé demande à
l'équipe d'organiser rapidement un
casting du non respect des stops et
l'asie pour des questions budgétaires
la production ne peut pas rajouter les
dinosaures en post production
une seule solution filmer directement de
vrais dinosaures des nos matchs poggi et
malgré la bonne volonté des habitants
c'est cette fois le réalisateur qui met
un frein aux projets déjà vu alors que
la situation s'enlise en production à
cause de l'égo du réalisateur sur place
l'ambiance reste pas bob legend loin du
narcissisme despotique d'un artiste
immature celui le 10 ans étant celui qui
est la narration continue
ainsi jane expérimente des techniques de
quatre nocturnes sous l'oeil amusé de
balle l'équipe profite même de ces
instants de répit pour régler quelques
derniers détails
les chorégraphies des combats sont mises
au point selon les directives de mal
des concept art de la fiche du film sont
réalisées par des artistes locaux
des groupes de musique sont auditionnés
pour composer la bande originale
nos choix de l'équipe se porte sur un
groupe de troubadours alternatif
l'épaule offre enfin acteur et
réalisateur trouve un compromis
scénaristique
sur les conseils de ti un informateur
locale qui prétend pouvoir les mener
jusqu'à la grotte des derniers vampire
nazis encore en activité l'équipe monte
une expédition par mesure de précaution
pop décide d'emmener avec eux cinq
vierge dont le sens fera diversion en
cas d'attaqué vampire durant des jours
l'équipe s'enfonce dans l'épaisse forêt
elle aussi inviolée enfin petit souffle
dans la planta bull signe qu'ils
viennent de pénétrer sur le territoire
des vampires nazis à partir de ce point
un camouflage de touristes allemands est
obligatoire
ce n'est que plusieurs kilomètres plus
loin de l'entrée de la grotte se dresse
enfin devant deux équipes et de torches
de fortune bob et jane pénètre dans
l'obscurité avec appréhension
malgré son palmarès impressionnant pop
n'a jamais négocié avec des vampires
tous espèrent que les vierges suffiront
à s'assurer leur collaboration
c'est une cruelle déception pour
l'équipe
trompé par le guide qui s'enfuit déjà en
hélicoptère bob et jane réalise que les
vampires sont en fait de simples chauve
souris dont l'obédience nazis semble
plus que douteuse pour bob cette
supercherie n'a vraiment rien de super
ok botte des usa bat cave and the bad à
batman batman nazi ce batman y est
habitué au bord de la rupture
c'est pourtant une découverte incroyable
qui attend l'équipe sans le savoir en
allant uriner bob vient de mettre à jour
un temple perdu depuis des millions
d'années en fouille au coeur de la
jungle
la cité légendaire de ping pong
représente un décor à l'authenticité
parfaitement préservée t6 de ruine est
coiffeur l'asie ce vampire mhp de
désistement besoins nationaux blues
swing hsd est sûre si tout ce qui y est
dit matt king and i would have known as
the way après les tests d'explosion le
feu vert des effets spéciaux est donné
pour bob et jane le repérage est
terminée si mathieu poggi and the lost
island sanous effectivement que le film
d'aventuré le plus ambitieux de tous les
temps il ne fait aucun doute que sa
suite repoussera encore les limites du
genre
les toutes dernières images envoyées par
baby jane sont encourageants